if someone else spoke to me the way that
I speak to myself you know I'd have to
kill that son of a [__] because you
know I couldn't tolerate that
I don't know why we're just so mean to
ourselves man
you know I get I don't know why I get so
addicted to things you know I'm even
addicted to damn nasal spray
you know that's about the hardest thing
I've had to kick to be honest with you
um
man I appreciate your honesty here uh
yeah look I had a non-addict I had a
non-addictive nasal spray that I had for
a while that
um I sometimes I pull up if I was going
to a bar or something I'd do a hitting
each nose before I go in it didn't even
do anything to me
it gave me a little bit of a flashback
of probably doing a drug or something
you know and just kind of heightened my
senses in in a weird way or
um
but yeah man I I'm sorry that you are so
mean to yourself
you know and I don't mean that as a
reflection of who uh you are because I
know
like me you don't want to be
you know you don't want to be
um
but if you're like us you have some of
this that we have this ISM this
alcoholism this
this uncomfort it's really an uncomfort
that just lives in US
um
yeah you probably can be real hard on
yourself
you know I think I was always re
extremely hard people that's the number
one note people have given me
now you're so hard on yourself
and I think I used to think that if I
wasn't hard on myself
then nobody was let me think about this
if I wasn't hard on myself
because when I was young nobody was
anything on me you know
and so I realized I thought maybe if I
was hard on myself or maybe if I was
perfect
you know I used to think I realized this
the other day I used to think that uh
well I expected myself to be perfect so
then I would never was because it's
impossible so then therefore I'm so hard
on myself
you know because I thought that I I
wasn't
cared for as a child and I'm not trying
to self-pity I'm just looking at what
was a part of my life
that
I wasn't cared for as a child so
therefore I took it on myself oh if I
was better
if I was perfect
then I would be loved you know I'm not
perfect enough
I'm not good enough
you know I'm not good enough for my
mother to see me I'm not good enough
um
for my father to stay alive I had this
Epiphany not long ago that I thought
that if I
was better
if I was perfect if I did everything
right as a kid I thought this I didn't
know until just recently that I thought
it but it came up
that if I did everything right that my
father would stay alive
that's what I thought for some reason as
a kid I
you know nobody explained to me what was
going on or how things worked or that
that was getting you know I just knew my
dad was older and that he was not going
to be alive for a long time and as a
child I thought maybe if I'm perfect
if I'm perfect you know
that my life would be different
you know and more specifically that my
dad would stay alive I thought that I
don't know how I came up with that or
what made me think that as a kid
but at least then it gave me some
control over what ha or what was going
to happen
because
now it's some of it's something it's up
to me
you know even though it's not realistic
it's impossible for that to come to
fruition but it's up to me then
so that's why I think I was so hard on
myself a lot of times I think because
then at least it
it puts it on me
which was the only thing that I felt I
could try and rely on anyway
um because I didn't feel comfortable in
the world
um
and that's not some down I'm not trying
to down or anybody uh
uh but I thought about that let's hear
more brother thanks for the call yeah
there's another picture for me man I
just wanted to tell you things and that
you want to learn man you know there's a
ton of days where your podcast is the
only time I smiled that day so
keep doing the Lord's work man take care
of yourself again
thanks bro
you too man you know I'm proud of you
dude it's hard uh you know
um
I'm proud of you
I'm proud of you because I know how hard
it is to take care of ourselves
you know I know how hard it is to take
care of ourselves I know that um
for me uh I never wanted to take care of
myself because if I took care of myself
then uh
that I was doing somebody else's job
instead I wanted to show I just always
wanted to show you how much I was
hurting you know
um
and so starting to take care of myself
was doing the opposite of that
and it was the opposite of the whole
thing that I didn't like oh you're gonna
assume when you look at me you're gonna
see how much I hurt
you know
um and starting to take care of myself
as a total opposite of that so I hear
that in you today and I'm I'm thankful
for that man I really am and I'm
grateful that I have moments like this
these are moments that mean something to
me you know two guys being trying to be
honest
and not even being gay and just being
um because these are moments I never had
as a child I never had there was never
any peace in my house there was never a
chance for anybody even to listen or to
be heard
there was never even any piece of space
to think or to feel there was no space
for that
and uh
and so it's moments like this you know
where I can have an honest conversation
with somebody
I'd have given anything if you know to
have these as a child and children need
these sort of things
um so anyway bro yeah enough [__]
enough of that [__] for me too bro but
praise man I'm happy for you
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one